france de mireille attendait d'eux on
arrête tout là non alors je comprend pas
le projet c'est quoi comment tu
t'appelles loucas louca déjà tu va
redescendre de deux étages je lis tu
fais quoi dans l'habitude l'est pas dans
la coiffure ration voir dos aux sports
dans le sport c'est quoi tu va remplacer
kelly ce soir quoi c'est pas tout mais
là bas tu dis rien ça ira très bien
c'est que mon fils jour soit est bien
sûr non
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai qu'être sourd
je dis surtout ses frères en us me plaît
pas kevin de sequana ton prénom ton cas
donc ton père dit il et il est cool ou
gary se mêlèrent comme dans l'émission
serait rien sans un type comme ça je
peux pas être cool est méchant mais est
incroyable et que son fils soit un ado
un problème c'est que c'est toi le
problème